-You mentioned Peter Thiel.
He's this big
Silicon Valley guy.
He had personal gripes
with Gawker.
-That's right.
-This was him using Hulk Hogan,
who he did not have
any relationship with,
basically,
to take vengeance on Gawker.
Interestingly, he's also a big
part of the Trump campaign.
He's a supporter
of Donald Trump.
Now we have a president,
who, I feel,
has the same idea
about the press
that Peter Thiel had
about Gawker.
Is there a fear now that
Donald Trump will be inspired
by what happened with Gawker
and that he will say,
"Oh, you know, basically,
if you have the legal team
with more money,
you can basically crush
these smaller news sources"?
-Absolutely. I think
there is a fear about that --
this basic
sort of chilling effect
that it might have
on news organizations.
Yeah. And part of it
is that Peter Thiel did this
in secret, right?
So he went after these people
in secret.
And -- And at the same time,
you could never quite separate
the case
from this crazy election cycle.
I mean, this is at the same time
Trump is saying --
you know, pointing at the press
at his rallies and speeches
and saying, "We're gonna,
you know, open up libel laws
and sue you like you've
never been seen sued before."
I mean,
he's calling the press scum
and horrible, horrible people
and all of that.
So -- And then, you know,
Peter Thiel became
a Trump supporter and all that.
So, yeah, you know, the --
"USA Today"
did a great story where --
that looked
at the 3,500 lawsuits
that Trump is involved with,
so I think
it's a very real concern.
-I find it very depressing
that a media organization,
any media organization,
can be put out of business
by a lawsuit.
Yet, there is --
in this era of Trump,
there are some, like,
positive signs of journalism.
-Yeah.
-"New York Times,"
"Washington Post" --
both have subscription bases
going up.
Do you feel like there is this
unique opportunity now for --
even at a time
where they're under attack --
for journalism
to sort of rise up
and maybe use this Trump moment
and this time we're living in
to be more robust?
-Yeah. Absolutely.
I do actually think that's one
of the sort of silver linings
of this Trump era,
this early time.
You know, I think, you know,
people have --
there's legitimate criticism
of media
that's gotten too corporatized
over time,
maybe got too cozy with power,
that it trades, you know,
softball stories
for access to power
and celebrity.
But, you know, I think that
you see the "Washington Post,"
and you see
"The New York Times,"
and you're starting to see
really great journalism.
So there's like this --
they're kind of remembering
what the press is there for.
I mean, look, you know,
journalism is,
almost by definition,
something that makes
powerful people uncomfortable,
and that's the point, right?
Speaking truth to power
is the point,
and we need this
in a participatory democracy.
So I think
if we're sort of remembering
what that's all about,
why it's important,
that can actually be
a good thing.
-Well,
I hope that comes to pass,
and congratulations
with the documentary.
It's a great story,
very well told.
-Thank you very much
for being here.
-Thanks.
-Brian Knappenberger, everybody.